[Applaudissements]
d'accord il est temps de faire le point
sur tout ce qui s'est passé sur les
réseaux sociaux et je vous le dis il ya
des choses très très drôle c'est netflix
et orange est levée
[Applaudissements]
comment il va se suicider a bien oui oui
oui il ya le petit et sans c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal dans salut les gars pardon
je vais pas eu françois viot
[Applaudissements]
il est très bon il est je te le dis il
faut le prendre en kit
oui c'est ce qu'on a pas les beaux
gosses iker alors les amis que vous
savez netflix suis un petit peu le le
dépositaire de l'autorité du web
ouais et on va tout de suite se pencher
sur le cas à noulens isère cédric 6 es
mon ami cédric est oui alors il faut
savoir que ces personnes s'aiment
beaucoup dans la vie ouais et se
fréquentent pas mal c'est finalement
elles ont même fini par fusionner je
vous présente cyril 6 r
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors un petit pas dans ce jeu là des
beautés ton je regarde beaucoup les
tétons c'est pas votre corps sa qua non
ah bah non non nova quoi les différences
avec des chants et des musiques la
gantoise c'est quoi la différence c'est
que les gens également beaucoup plus
musclé plus dans votre profil mais de
façon moi tout ce que c'est pas vous n'a
pas besoin mais pas de discussion
évidemment rien apollon et là on sait
pas ce que tu vois la magnifique où on
va dire que oui alors c'est pas sympa
pour cédric 6r merci à lui voulu dire et
de marc à exactement
alors vous le savez les amis hier on
avait deux magnifiques d'invités c'est
vrai à m sila et alban ivanov
il faut savoir que alban il était
surexcité hier même dans les loges
il nous a mis l'ambiance
c'est leur égard
je
ça c'est un truc que je peux faire
j'adore ce mec j'adore ce mec mais ça
leur ferait pas ce soir ça me chauffe ça
me savonner la planche
alors vous m'avez demandé aussi de
regarder un petit peu twitter léger
fruité nature j'aimerais qu'on parle un
petit peu notre ami jonathan o'donnell
il nous a sorti un tweet de la redoute
c'est magnifique j'aimerais qu'on
regarde alors à la base ils vendent 1
marcel ouais donc un débardeur
exactement mais il faut savoir que ça
j'ai comme dès les séries le truc oui
évidemment
ok on n'a pas le magnéto tâter du
[Applaudissements]
secteur bancaire il est bas et des bas
j'ai vu tout d'abord eu de nice ainsi la
zone c'est un grand bravo à coucher
vraiment vraiment en forme les chairs
tout ça et ça crée beaucoup de clips en
lycra
ah oui c'est un bébé vraiment c'était
vraiment ça ça moult chaque parti qui
n'ont pas les verts alors les règles sur
les ij tu étais vraiment se suivent et
nos folles
je suis mais nos fans vous en avez
forcément oui oui été arrêté je loue
déjà dit chic je n'avais pas d'ici
comment alimenter le corps spongieux
sinon michel cymes et vous avez raison
parce que c'est désastreux pour les
spermatozoïdes micra whitson
merci salut c'est d'aller sur un autre
domaine là cette semaine celui qui a
fait le buzz c'est un steward les amis
alors vous savez d'habitude quand on
prend l'avion on déteste écouté les
consignes de sécurité sur et là je nous
ai trouvé une pépite
moi personnellement j'ai envie de le
regarder pendant des heures ils
apprendraient la pente
c'est à dire
c'est benjamin castaldi qui est fait
l'amour dans l'avion avec une personne
très connue une politique
ah oui on allait à tahiti c'est ça en
revenant de los angeles à los angeles
lors des matchs et aussi je crois dans
l'avion absolument trois bassins trois
formes mais dans le même avion trois
personnes différentes dans 3ème journée
du personnel une fois personne ne sait
quel hacker l'équipe c qui était
compagnies aurifères la vue mais elle
existe cette compagnie ne vous fait pas
de mal à l'estomac
corsair c'est là qu'elle ait pu mots
c'est vrai ses biceps des stewards de
corsair j'ai pas si l'on doit recruter
comment justement j'ai une petite
surprise pour vous les amis vous savez
que touche pas à mon poste et regarder
dans les quatre coins de la planète
il ya une fidèle téléspectatrice qui
avait un message à nous adresser pour un
des chroniqueurs non casta cpo watts
ah non
[Applaudissements]
sa mort est sage
ces constats les malentendus que je
pourrais tu l'as pas vu de façon on se
quitte sur une dernière image et
messieurs les amis j'ai trouvé le leur
mare de la semaine abdul ilah les rails
celui-ci en fait il est parti à la pêche
mais visiblement il avait oublié son
épuisette
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait plaisir d'avoir des nouvelles de
jean luc lemoine et on y voit jean
lutter comme invitée dans l'émission
pour sa nouvelle émission sur france 3
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]